number twenty how did they make a Jew
kill the Gestapo I don't know in Frank
huh oh my god that's holy question the
day for people on YouTube are you yet
are you now yet getting notifications we
tried to send an email out to the people
at the youtubes and some people still
aren't getting notifications if you
aren't bookmark join my club please okay
news the day is a hundred percent a true
story go to the BBC we have the links up
the website dirty jokes apparently have
now been discovered in the hidden pages
of Anne Frank's diary the director DC
two new pages from Anne Frank's diary
have been published containing a handful
of dirty jokes and her thoughts on sex
the hidden pages have been covered with
gummed brown paper apparently to hide
her risque writing from her family true
story which brings us to this week's 7+1
[Music]
only slight change it's not 7 plus 1
like we said we sat down ran out of meat
segments 3 it was me not gay Jared oh
and Benjamin and then we just said I we
have like we have like 40 and Frank
dirty and Frank Joe's going with
extended mags that's about it and it's
not add some to write good ok so these
are the 7 plus 125 whatever it is dirty
and frank jokes that we have from from
Anne Frank's diary that they have
discovered now it's like the Dead Sea
Scrolls of dirty jokes so send computer
actually I think this is you know this
this is something you should probably
lead us off with because it's probably
closer to how Frank sounded is off so
number one number one why did Hitler
never release a sex tape no one wants to
watch a masturbate yeah we got the
number don't forget computer number two
why is that beep I'll do it for you son
this is not a good start number two
number two BB why is it always
constipated after you created the SS all
that balls were taken
all right all right Anne Frank who
number three am i from Anne Frank I'll
go back to you soon how can how can you
tell an SS from a [ __ ] one is dumb
mocked and generally useless the other
is a [ __ ] ha ha ha number four knock
knock who's that Hitler how did you find
me why did I come in let's have
indicating a getting run over by a car
all right now KJ you're up all right
why did the SS cross the road so you
could be a total item somewhere new you
got to do the Germans what everyone has
to do German not really okay so Sam
let's take us back to where it all
started
number six be beaten yeah how many hit
list does it take to change a light bulb
3 1 2 change a light bulb and 2 to hold
us hands steady from the tremors caused
by meth and Parkinson it's almost argued
and Frank at this point could have known
that informations very very much it
almost seems as though she was a
clairvoyant again the dirty the dirty
jokes found Anne Frank's diary and yes
you did wear a shiny shirt I don't know
what it is it's like you just go to the
Liberace rec the man your choice rest
comfortably he goes in and says yes I
would like to spend a lot of money and
an air of goodness a behind the
candelabra it's nothing bad number 7 how
many SS does it take to screw in a
lightbulb
7 SS Susanne Frank 1 to screw in the
light bulb and 60 blames the failure of
the own light bulb shortcomings on the
Jews a full-time job
yes tries again all right which one
number 8 rate and Frank and Frank's
diary number DSS crossroad
vie to the 2nd SS cross zero second I
couldn't hear it sound like you said
second why didn't expect like Prosecco
did you actually say my life
okay I just wanna make sure because it's
the 2nd SS cross Z road I don't know
because he was stuck inside the fun
Frenchman the Frenchman is number 9 why
did the Frenchman switch from red wine
to right wine because a German told him
to and then the German little bit angsty
teenage and Frank oh my god all right
Sven computer
let's bring us up to the next one here
all right BP number 10
yeah why do you stop will not get raped
in hell I don't know Anne Frank because
they are none of God's chosen people
that was good discovery and Frank's
diary dirty jokes it's up at BBC it is a
true story it's a genre there's been no
fabrication here number 11 I guess top
old dies yeah and goes to the gates of
heaven so is a man at the gate with book
of names the Gestapo approaches him and
asks angelic figure I have carried out
the Lord's work this is long setup may I
empty this gate the man says please tell
me your name and I will see if you may
enter the Gestapo gives him his name as
he searches the book ah says the bearded
man here you are I see you did a lot
with your time on earth I can grant you
your request
he smiles as the SS man walks towards
the gates of heaven already to meet him
hit me to the afterlife and Jubilee once
he rises the gates however they remain
shut confused
the Gestapo turns back and says what
gives the man its gates answers Oh gate
I thought you said the rake and if I
need to edit for so little pay off man
yeah and Frank if you can hear us will
down the set up of you uh-huh keep it
short
all right time is precious - now go
Jarrett let's give you you're at number
12 here over 12
how many Frenchmen does it take to screw
in a light bulb
I don't know when Frank 15 million they
also voted immediately in the life of me
remain unchanged kinkow
oh gosh it always seems like she just
wrote that that was inner monologue
that's how it Indian to number 13 lucky
number why don't Nazis and the Irish
have children was a bit too drunk to
commit genocide number 14 why did the
German get in trouble with the taxman
trend computer what's what why they
because he gassed all the accountants
that would almost that doesn't seem like
Anne Frank would laugh at her what's it
what's number
what's number 15 Stein computer number
15 baby did you hear about the Nazi who
helped the old lady cross the road no
Anne Frank me neither
they're all dicks sometimes knew how to
zag when you expected her to Zig oh let
me said this is the bulk of today's show
we just sat down and just couldn't get
enough Anne Frank jokes
oh and Owen thank you brother we
appreciate this one's for you have um
all right son computer let's give you a
number let's give you this next one
might as well you're not my 16 yeah
what's the difference between a
porcupine and Joe and occupy occupation
baby I don't know where's Anne Frank
with porcupine the pricks on the outside
have you read number 17 then we'll all
right number 17 be beep what's the
difference between in Jewish and Nazi
accountants I don't know Anne Frank
you're getting some rough territory I
see one balances your books the other
burns them like that's didn't compute
that one properly all right knock hey
Jared I think you have a number uh
number 18 out of 25 24 why did I not see
whether the Nazi feel driver's ed I did
not see failed Javas ed because he was
it turns on all into left turns but
failed on the Third Reich there's a dad
joke a priest a Jew and a Nazi
walk into a bar by the end of the night
the priest leaves was an altar boy it's
a Nazi leaves at the Frenchman's wife
and the Jew leaves were
the Lord's blessing which we already
have anyway so you're Nazis this is
reading from Anne Frank's diary we have
it you can see the part you had some
anger and your letters all right you
know what let's uh
German accent let's go edgy Morgan Jr
give it your best good lord we got the
number from Anne Frank's money number 20
how did the naked you kill the Gestapo I
don't know in Frank huh oh my god that's
holy [ __ ] beep beep no no that's that's
that's that's not a joke at the expense
of Nazis that's it was almost dark
summary of the Holocaust it was on the
list it's not on the list it's not a
list at all you know let's talk about
that can we all can we all confirm that
just don't don't hold us responsible
number 21
how many Nazis does it take to screw in
a light bulb just fun but it's not the
light bulb it's zyklon-b
oh okay okay timeout you you have their
cans you twist them yes yes exactly all
right number backside number true number
22 how do you drown a stupid guest Apple
I'm just still a Jew alive at the bottom
of the lake
thank you Anne Frank four years of jail
right and spending computer take us out
with the final joke from Anne Frank's
diary the dirty joke according to BBC
yes
number 23 baby how can you tell you
stopped her from a smelly hot festering
pouch eat the corn subscribe watch one
of these other videos or hit the
notification Bell well you should hit
that if you subscribe anyways because
subscriptions don't mean anything on
YouTube anymore now you have to get
notifications and it shows up in your
inbox so I don't know why you subscribed
in the first place because what we have
to do also we're not making money off
these videos anymore because YouTube
decided why they just said we're not
going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you should up to your job do your work
and then they said hey by the way we're
not gonna pay you said why they said
piss off